If anybody thinks in South Africa
that you can take the land without compensation,
you living in a dream.
Let me put it quite frankly to you.
If you want to start a civil war in South Africa,
do that. Do that.
And I told you before,
I told you before that don't.
I don't think it's,
it's decidedly.
What are you raising?
On a member.
On a point of order.
On which rule,
honourable member?
The rule that establishes point of order.
You know what is the rule?
But the point of order is
he can't stand there and threaten civil war
for a radical program of land occupation.
It's not parliamentary to threaten civil war.
If you want civil war change.
Thank you very much.
Thank you. Don't,
don't threaten it there.
Thank you. I think.
Honourable member
must never threaten civil war.
You know nothing about war.
Honourable member.
Thank you. You are pointless in wage. Thank you.
Thank you. Please.